cette semaine on a eu envie de mettre à
l'honneur serge gainsbourg car lundi
prochain cela fera 29 ans qui nous a
quittés pour célébrer l'homme à la tête
de chou comme on l'appelait on a deux
invités incroyable avec nous ce soir on
accueille constance meyer qui avec une
histoire d'amour avec serge gainsbourg
durant les cinq dernières années de sa
vie c'est d'ailleurs delpont qui parle
dans la chanson plus doux avec moi
lorsqu'il dit constant avec
l'inconstance tu ne sais pas où tu vas
et il ya jean jacques debout auteur
compositeur interprète amis proches de
serge gainsbourg pendant plus de trente
ans mais d'abord pour les plus jeunes
serge gainsbourg c'était ça regarde
[Musique]
je mens
je
jour de gloire médiatique les tendeurs
[Musique]
je
m
[Musique]
ces violences mais hier des éclaircies
constance d'être la constance des vécu
une histoire d'amour avec serge
gainsbourg
durant les cinq dernières années de sa
vie où je les dis un instant c'est
d'ailleurs de vous dont il parle dans la
chanson plus doux avec moi lorsqu'il dit
constant dans l'inconstance tu ne sais
pas où tu vas vous avez d'ailleurs écrit
un livre la jeune fille et gainsbourg
aux éditions l'archipel où vous dévoiler
tous vos souvenirs dans l'intimité du
chanteur merci d'être avec nous ce soir
[Applaudissements]
une personne que j'adore en bas il le
sait c'est jean jacques debout un
immense artiste auteur compositeur
interprète amis proches de serge
gainsbourg pendant plus de trente ans
vous avez composé pour les plus grands
retrouve d'ailleurs dans votre album
il chante jean jacques debout on vous
retrouve avec johnny hallyday sylvie
vartan yves montand sheila michel
delpech barbara dalida tous les deux
vous avez fréquenté serge gainsbourg de
très près vous avez plein d'anecdotes à
nous raconter bien sûr fabien lecoeuvre
et bernard montiel aussi au fond des
choses
moi aussi j'en ai bien sûr il faut
l'installer merci
[Applaudissements]
jean jacques debout regardez comme jean
jacques qui vient de fêter ses 80 ans
n'ont pas encore le 9 mars ses 9 mars et
match et voilà 9 mars bombail mais vient
de fêter ses cinquante quatre ans de
mariage avec chantal davantage quelques
jours franchement j'ai déjà soulier qui
violent la pire
merci d'être avec nous et c'est bien sûr
la case hors cac avec toute l'équipe et
on a la chance d'avoir constance meyer
avec nous la jeune fille et gainsbourg
vous avez vécu donc une histoire d'amour
avec serge gainsbourg
durant les cinq dernières années de sa
vie constance meyer la jeune fille et
gainsbourg c'est aux éditions l'archipel
de poche et on à jean jacques debout
[Applaudissements]
dont jacques trim ans artistes et amis
proches bien sûr de serge gainsbourg et
là dedans voilà je peux vous dire voilà
il a composé pour tout le monde un
jean-jacques c'est un des plus grands
compositeurs de l'histoire
fabien c'est une base de mousse et non
jean jacques debout est une star en 58
hallyday n'a pas encore fait carrière
il rit voit à travers à travers une
brasserie y voit le jean jacques debout
qui entraîne dîner à la terrasse avant
de rejoindre l'inca et le jeune hallyday
jean philippe smet tape au chaos demande
un autographe à jean jacques debout sur
un sous bocks de bière
l'offre est et deux bouts lui permet à
john à l'idée de rentrer pour la
première fois à l'olympia les voir john
vincent l'idole johnny absolument c'est
une vraie ce que serge gainsbourg et
jane et idées s'entendait pas trop bien
au début c'était passé vibrer et puis
après ça a commencé à aller mieux à
partir du moment où dans un numéro 1 de
cartes entier ils ont chanté ensemble
qu'à la vieille canaille d'accord alors
là ils se sont plus quittés et et tout
s'est arrangé avec avec la chanson des
villes de vieilles canailles alors avoir
trouvé surtout premier passage télé à
serge gainsbourg c'était le 29 mars 1958
dans l'émission chez vous ce soir
présenté par michèle arnaud fait qu'il
avait connue en tant que musicien dans
le cabaret où elle chantait elle
explique d'ailleurs qu'elle le pensait
muet tellement il était timide et serge
gainsbourg à regarder serge gainsbourg
je l' ai connu il ya déjà deux ou trois
ans dans le cabaret où je chante il
jouait de la guitare et jouer du piano
comme ce n'est pas un monsieur très
communicatif la belge avait pensé
pendant longtemps qu'il était muet enfin
vous allez l'entendre et vous allez
pouvoir en juger
[Musique]
je suis moins solaire délirant
le gabon trois écrans le regarde pas
[Musique]
c'est vrai que il était très complexe et
il paraît pas resaler dit qu'il était
très laid constance il vous en parler ou
pas et vous le disais saint-louis
beaucoup il avait un grand complexe de
laideur il il a beaucoup souffert en
fait c'est un garçon un petit garçon
très mignon et il a beaucoup souffert
l'adolescence parce que il s'est fait
jeter par toutes les filles
oui ça ça l'a marqué 62 a poussé 10 est
certainement et je pense que ça a duré
jusqu'à bardot jusqu'à ce qu'il
rencontre bardot ou d'abord là il
commence à avoir les cheveux un peu plus
l'on voit moins ses oreilles et vannes
le fait de sortir avec bardot qui était
considérée comme la plus belle femme de
france là quand même
réconforté enfin bien sûr mais en
confiant elle est magnifique
justement sa timidité lui a créé pas mal
de problèmes tout à l'heure vous évoquez
le petit dilemme avec johnny hallyday
il ya eu aussi un problème avec jacques
dutronc il pensait que jacques dutronc
ne l'aimé pas donc il n'aimait pas
jacques dutronc et il a fallu que
françoise hardy les mettent ensemble et
il a eu aussi un autre problème avec
alain delon
quand jane birkin tourner la piscine il
est allé tous les jours sur le tournage
persuadé que dollon aller le week-end
jane birkin
ouais ça a été l'enfer pour sur le
tournage à cause de joie et non mais
alors et c'est vrai qu'il a quand même
dit qu'il n'écrirait jamais pour johnny
oui c'est à dire j'étais jeune j'étais
arrivé comme tout le monde au
saint-hilaire rue de ponthieu et puis je
tombe sur serge qui est qu'ils étaient
là et puis il me regarde et puis me dis
dis moi j'ai entendu une chanson qui
fait un peu western
pour moi la vie va commencer il me dis
moi tu vois j'écrirai jamais pour ce
conte l'art et tout ce que c'est vous
qui avez écrit pour moi la vie va
commencer mais oui mais à moi ils me
disent j'ai créé à gérer pour ça qu'on
l'a oui mais alors j'ai du coup de serge
tu le connais tu le connais pas ça
prouve que tu le connais pas parce que
si moi je sais intimement que si vous
rencontrez tu parle pas de lui comme ça
et je suis sûr qu'un jour tu lui écrire
des chansons
il me dit ah bah ça alors là c'est pas
demain la veille et puis évidemment moi
j'avais répété à johnny bien sûr alors
johnny m'avait dit bon ben si je le vois
je lui mette mon poing dans la gueule
et puis un jour je nie évidemment arrive
au saint-hilaire serge était là et puis
se sont assis l'un à côté de l'autre
puis sont mis à discuter a parlé de
chansons tout s'est arrangé et c'est pas
très loin
l'époque où il a chanté avec eddy
mitchell la chanson tous les trois ça se
monte à visa chantait jacques dutronc et
eddy mitchell loi alors constance
vous dites dans votre livre ne pas le
reconnaître à cette époque maintenant
c'est vrai mais je peux pas être la
seule
ouais et le pauvre il me fait de la
peine n'a rien lâché de la peine on
reçoit tellement clim ine il est il est
match d'ailleurs enfin moi j'aimais bien
quand il était après à partir de 40 ans
après et après ils étaient vous vous
trouviez vous j'en ai parlé à pas mal de
gens qu'il a rencontrés tout le monde a
dit la même chose quand on le voyait il
avait tellement d' allure tellement de
charme tellement de classe
oui il était beau ce alors vous l'avez
rencontrée à quel âge vous 16 à 16 ans
et l'huile avec l âge 57 57
ah ouais mais moi j'étais assez mature
et lui c'est un grand enfant
d'accord ouais mais bon je suis sûr que
la différence d'âge finalement n'était
pas très présente en dorthe pour la
maladie et la mort parce que vous avez
quand même 2 fabien lecoeuvre des 40
quand on lit son livre elle explique
très bien la première fois où vous
monter dans la chambre de serge vous
regardez des films toute la nuit
ces pays m'a pas sauté dessus ça a duré
trois mois et un peu mais c'est moi qui
vais le chercher
ah d'accord alors serge gainsbourg était
un amoureux des mots et de la poésie
comme toi jean-jacques 1 c'est vrai
comme vous on a voulu revoir son
entretien sur le plateau de bernard
pivot 80 le chanteur initie le
journaliste à ses proses mais des proses
sur les pets regardez c'est un petit peu
quand même un peu obsédé par les wampas
que dans un autre livre qui est paru
cette année mais qui vous est consacré
s'appelle serge gainsbourg il y a sorte
de récit de votre vie et puis il y à la
fin des des paroles de chansons et j'ai
découvert une chanson qui s'appelle des
vents des ped et poum
il ya aussi un petit un petit 4 1 oui
gaz à tous les étages mais pas mais ça
oui c'est ça oui ça là aussi milliers de
danse avec ma petite kate sûr de ma
braguette je puisse se paie 30 ans j'ai
quelques réalités où il ya de tout vous
dites constance dans votre livre que il
travaillait comme à la dernière minute à
chaque fois ça gêne bon c'était pas un
gros bosseur où c'était non pas du tout
ce n'est pas beaucoup
je suis venu travailler mais pas
beaucoup parce que il qu'il travaillait
au dernier moment et à toute vitesse
c'est un album en qu'un show alors il
était très drôle serge gainsbourg il
nourrissait un mois là il aurait été
incroyable dans la grosse rigolade stern
est nommé invités rêver regardez cet
extrait sur le plateau de nulle part
ailleurs où il raconte une vanne à côté
de sa marionnette des guignols regarde
une élocution un peu comme ça et qui
commençait parce que je me suis tu es
trop juste oublié et puis me 18 12 date
de docteur je suis bien trop gros
calibres trop convenu que ça fait pas
beaucoup
et oui tu me fais bien d'écouter ont
lieu votre défaut d'élocution vient
l'appréhension vous avez de la blesser
alors moi je vous en couper la moitié
qui vous en couper un métier et une
question par personne tout et que vous
croyez
bon bon coup par morceau les joies ya
quinze jours après 10h et le ketchup et
que tu deviens le croit que la petite
bande ku et étudiants avec même trac de
folie qu est ce que vous pourriez pas
m'en irai fait le métier et tout bbc à
cette étape à pau pas possible constance
vous dites que c'est la personne la plus
drôle que vous ayez connu certainement
en tout cas ça fait plaisir de revoir ça
parce que c'était une blague qui
racontait effectivement à l'époque et le
premier sac j'ai dîné avec lui il était
très timide
moi aussi quand même et il m'a sorti
tout son répertoire de blague
ah ouais ça durait deux heures et
j'étais un spectacle vous rigolez c'est
l'acteur le réalisateur il voyait tout
il est il le faisait lé père noël et les
accents bien sûr il est étonnant et
alors c'était aussi une grande gueule on
avait plusieurs fois s'énerver à la télé
en 82 dans l'émission droit de réponse
serge gainsbourg s'agace face aux
critiques du journal satirique minutes
et à son journaliste regarder journal
satirique minutes
alagui que j'ai dès que je me suis
dégonflé à strasbourg ce qui est absolu
de demandes de la délation car j'ai mis
les parents ou pas voilà j'avais le bas
comme sa mairie et monsieur jean
françois kahn qui est là on a la preuve
des génies attend vous êtes vraiment
et c'est vous qui devriez va gagner sont
trop si tu sais pourquoi parce qu'on
vient reprocher d'avoir changé de la
marseillaise à cause de ces terrains etc
c'était dans la notation des textes
quand il y avait un refrain au lieu de
recopier le refrain intégralement
m'étais aux armes etc donc lui il a pris
la partition elle a pris le texte
original il a eu cette idée géniale de
dire aux armes etc ne pas répéter le
refrain et il a eu la grippe procine
bonne grâce à sa manette ça vous le
saviez enfin bien oui parce que rouget
de lisle à l'époque surpris celui qui a
écrit la marseillaise aurait copié
lui-même pour donner à des gens qui
voulaient avoir la marseillaise
est ce que dit francis est très juste au
lieu de recopier à chaque fois aux armes
et ça permettait oui mais limitée etc
il y avait un truc sur lequel ne
rigolait pas du tout ce sont ses enfants
la preuve en est durant la présentation
du film charlotte for ever en 86 animé
par patrick sabatier le présentateur lui
demande si ce n'est pas un peu faire de
l'exhibitionnisme en montrant sa fille
au cinéma et là il est chaud regarde toi
est ce que vous n'avez pas l'impression
serge gainsbourg de faire de
l'exhibitionnisme mon pour votre fille
au cinéma il est français efface son
sourire
seillant ça va chier
je vous pose la question répondez moi si
elle fait déjà deux films ok well
allumons sénat j'ai dit ok à papa non
pas que charlotte ça trouble ce trouble
pas tout toute scolarité c'est pendant
les vacances ce que charles a voulu
maintenant je lui pose une question de
mois qu'ils me répondent qu'ils savaient
que ces plateaux et me sens tout à
l'heure justement moi je les ai reçus
pour ce film c'était en 86 ah oui ou non
c'est à l'époque c'était faire pour
aquitaine que je faisais le cinéma est
donc effectivement c'était la question
qu'il fallait pas lui poser
c'était parce que justement dans le film
c'est absolument pas ça vous lui aviez
posé vous ben non parce que d'abord je
vous dire quand elle est arrivée tout le
monde a dit ne lui pose pas la question
il est très énervé en fait m'a juste
demandé une bouteille de blanc qui ces
sifflets en direct la télé ce qui était
formellement interdit
à quand les puits mais tout s'est très
bien passé il est extrêmement
sympathique extrêmement c'est fait c'est
un beau souvenir pont à excellent
souvenir depuis qu'on s'est vus on est
sorti j'ai eu un accident de voiture à
cause de lui alors amenant donc il a
fait ma télé après on va dîner au resto
évidemment il boit bien moi aussi
d'ailleurs
et à un moment on avait rendez vous dans
une boîte où vous voulez vous voulez
aller en boîte à bordeaux et à maurin
sur le périphérique à bordeaux il me dit
vas-y foncé rôle sur le boulevard france
france c'était rouge
alors ma vie bon gainsbourg à côté c'est
quand même pas mal soit je fonce comme
un crime
en plus c'était ma première voiture une
voiture pourrie en plus gros carton en
gros carton létal est à l'hôpital et il
a fait envoyer à tous les infirmiers du
champagne vins de tous il était adorable
on a fini comme la sors en boîte
oui il m'a pété la bagnole et repartir
en voitures de pompiers ce qu'il adorait
faire à travers berlin
tu te laisserai pas salir sa jeunesse
boxe était un grand séducteur
on le voit avec constance à voile a vécu
cinq ans et depuis cette magnifique
non mais c'est vrai que signifient ces
types donc un grand séducteur il a
d'ailleurs fréquenté les plus belles
femmes de l'époque son idylle avec
brigitte bardot a duré seulement trois
mois mais a été très intense à la
bouleverser son idylle avec brigitte
bardot
jean-jacques oui il adorait ouais c'est
quand même pour elle pendant là qu'il a
créée je t'aime moi non plus quoi ça a
duré que trois mois mais elle était
mariée de l'acquitter de brigitte bardot
oui il l'avait menacé bréger de divorcer
bref c'est normal c'est 30 avec un autre
mec sorti la chanson et après on
comprend pas la lch alors c'est surtout
pardo et et gainsbourg enregistre le
dise le 10 octobre 1967 la chanson je
t'aime moi là et elle est mariée avec
gunter sachs
c'est un des milliardaires qui lui offre
des bijoux toute la journée etc
et à un moment donné elle passe sur
l'antenne d'europe 1 pour la première
fois la chanson à 11h39 gambiens et
gunther gunter sachs était important
c'est cuit l'entente ça il peut pas
supporter bien sûr espèce de 2,2 de coït
chanter enfin c'est s était dérangeant
pour lui il était marié il passé pour le
cocu de la planète
bien sûr à interdire le disque
évidemment et leur liaison entre bardot
et gainsbourg s'est arrêté là quand même
alors même s'il se trouvait les serge
gainsbourg plaisait énormément
voilà c'est vrai qu'il avait un énorme
sur charme avec les filles la preuve en
est dans l'émission le jeu de la vérité
en 85
lorsqu'il se fait clairement chauffer au
téléphone par une téléspectatrice
regarde
pelé il y aurait vendu bio frapin tu
vraiment fantastique
adam on est toutes un groupe là et on
t'aime bien
alors je te poser ma question est donc
île déserte on va voir un petit coin
aqib erreurs aussi mignon sans adresser
des fonds et vous m'expliquer comment à
travers ses chansons
vous pouvez déclencher des envies
sexuelles et des tonnerres d'orgueil
chez les femmes ici juge saisi doit
avoir une voix sexy un peu comique et
m'a aussi aidé quand j'aurai une longue
queue on va si vous êtes client
on va peut-être passer un autre thème je
vous remercie d'avoir posé cette
question
[Applaudissements]
bonjour patrick sabatier très très cool
un tranquille allez on va passer
maintenant chantal goya
c'est fou ça ça c'est incroyable
il avait beaucoup de succès il était
absolument charmant et il était très
classe avec les femmes il les mettait en
valeur il draguait pas beaucoup il
essaie quand même timide assez il avait
pas besoin de draguer il était charmant
issus à lui il faut pas oublier qu'il
avait quand même il avait du sens oui
c'était un prince russe c'est un gaz
dont c'était comme un prince russe
alors alors je vais vous dire il est il
à des techniques particulières pour
draguer il ya une séquence qu'on a tous
vu bien sûr la séquence culte on est
obligé de remettre ce soir c'est avec
vous donnez houston elizéon 86 bon là
c'est c'est pas la meilleure drague
regardez ces mesures agréées libye que
vous êtes très joli jeu c'est son goût
du dinar mais yoann autres reagan annoot
courbettes kovatchev saut du rail un
highside à world of soccer
alors je vous traduire non non
il dit vous êtes très joli non non non
non non c'est non il a dit ça mais ça je
peux pas vous traduire ce qu'il allait
il a dit j'aimerais bien vous avez place
pas du tout j'ai dit jean geiler apaisé
mais il a dit il est normal vous
imaginez quand ils essuient savons faire
et sa constance ou pas ouais ouais ça me
fait marrer j'étais là vous étiez là
ouais j'étais dans le club mais qu'est
ce qui vous a dit après vous avez dit
quoi il n'a pas du tout compris ah oui
il a dit à son producteur j'étais bien
rien parce que sa fin politique capable
d'imaginer que ce serait comme stone n'a
plus voulu faire télé en france pendant
des années je crois que de requins a été
obligé lui aux fleurs dans ce spectacle
est en fait il voulait lui dire moi il a
complètement il est passé un peu à côté
mecs qu'elle était belle qu'elle était
désirable c'est ça ouais on to fuck her
oui enfin tu peu d'anglais oui non mais
c'est surtout qu'on avait expliqué à
whitney houston de c'était la plus
grosse émission france face à la
joufflue prestigieuse qu'elle allait
être reçu comme une reine et comme une
immense star le risque à la carrière
voilà alors là ça a été les attachés de
presse en coulisses et les managers les
dires et artistique tout le monde s'est
offusqué moi j'étais sur le plateau
aussi à quelques mètres ce que
j'accompagnais à l'époque pour walt
disney douchka et et davy crockett bien
sûr donc que chacun on est comme ex
toi tu étais avec davy crockett voir ces
bonnes questions
david près enfin walt disney est énorme
bien sûr alors c'est un provocateur
serge gainsbourg aux provocations très
célèbre le billet de 500 francs qu'il a
décidé de brûler sur le plateau de 7 sur
7 ans 84 pour dénoncer le racket fiscal
regarde le racket d imposer le mien ça
c'est pas une part de ces du fil je
prends un billet de 500 balles
je suis taxé à ça c'est illégal strict
c'est illégal au fantôme je vais vous
dire si west s'arrêterait à 74%
il faut quand même pas déconner parce
que ça c'est pas pour les pauvres c'est
pour le nucléaire
voilà voilà ce qu ils veulent c ur et ça
c'est incroyable
[Applaudissements]
il a préparé son coup mais surtout le
biais les 26% du billet qui restait de
500 francs à l'époque a été vendue il ya
quatre ans non seize mille euros et moi
j'étais l'experte cette vente justement
c'est incroyable je connais bien les
croquettes et c'est un document
aujourd'hui qui est conservé dans un
musée
ça sera tellement fait bernard barbet il
faut reconnaître qu'à l'époque c'était
une énorme scandale
tous les jours c'est ce jour-là on et
gainsbarre g20 boulet je t'encule mois
[Rires]
l'oseille mois alors il était très
généreux
serge gainsbourg puisqu'en 85 sur le
plateau du jeu de la vérité une
téléspectatrice lui reproche de ne pas
avoir participé à la chanson de renaud
ethiopie contre la famine interprétée
par de nombreux artistes français serge
va leur faire un chèque de 100 mille
francs en direct destiné à l'association
médecins sans frontières regarder tous
les connards qui sont pas les potes de
renault et tuant gervais sur ce disque
je je je dire ceci fait que moi c'est
comme je m'attendais la question stylo à
paris xième le 7 juin 1985
c'est signé son rival à médecins sans
frontières
patrick sabatier regarde c'est normal
qu'ils soient pas faire une barbe la
constance il était très généreux traîne
il était il était fauché quand il était
jeune il n'avait pas beaucoup de moyens
et ils avaient vraiment conscience de ce
que tu es l'argent et d' avoir galéré
paraît que vous avez une anecdote paris
qu'un jeune âge dont dans la rue qui lui
a demandé de l'argent
ouais un jeune lui a dit gainsbarre ta
pata pata pas s'emballer il y a donné
500 balles mais ça l'est beaucoup plus
loin quand on rentrait dans les
restaurants ils allaient d'abord dans
les cuisines il donné 500 balles à
chaque cuisinier et 500 balles à chaque
serveur et quand il appeler un taxi
les taxes il savait que le pourboire
c'était 500 francs il se battait pour
avoir la course et il avait dans sa
mallette des liasses de 500 francs ah
oui quand-même marie et des taxes
assurément quoi justement vous donnez
pas sans s'emballe à chaque samedi
bonjour c'est pas ça redonne 500 valence
il invitait tout le monde serge
gainsbourg oui ils étaient franchement
il comptait pas quand il aimait les gens
qu'il était heureux quelque part il dit
lui avait rien de trop beau pour ses
copains c'est ça ouais bah comme comme
toi baffie rien trop pour ces gros
bonnets en charge il y en a un qui était
comme ça c'est que les chats coluche et
gâteaux ou génie s'assure que lui choisi
parce que aucun fait mode
il y avait tous les serveurs qui était
là depuis des décennies et coluche était
tellement généreux ils essaient de tel
pour boire qui a un serveur qui a pu
prendre un crédit sachent qu'ils barak
grâce aux pourboires de coluche non et
quand coluche s'est tué en moto
il a paniqué pour son crédit il était
très triste bien sûr mais il était très
généraux sont très bonnes avec d'autres
de lolo c'était un homme très sensible
aussi serge gainsbourg on a retrouvé un
moment de télévision très fort c'était
dans l'émission sébastien c'est fou en
la chorale des petits chanteurs
d'asnières reprennent je suis venu te
dire que je m'en vais avec un verre de
champagne ont en main et une cigarette
on chocolat et regardez la réaction de
st chamond
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais des provocations qui change
[Musique]
mais
il ya bien aussi
[Musique]
chére mélodies monde agricole
toi
[Musique]
l'âge des cheveux
les sig en eux des yeux d'un coup
empêché ta jeunesse
ça jamais
elle est
[Applaudissements]
je trouve ça bien sûr le voir pleurer
moi c'est vrai qu'ils avaient la larme
facile et stan ultra sensible qui passer
du rire aux larmes assez facilement mais
là il y avait tout pour lui plaire
l'enfant si les six têtes un enfant
habillé comme lui avec les paroles
adaptées
c'est vrai que c'est à tomber non non
mais c'est à un grand génie parce que là
par exemple cette chanson je suis venu
te dis on sait très bien que c'est vers
l'est par exemple pour les monnaies qui
s'est inspiré de chopin je sais pour
nice a levé vie c'était vrac c'est un
génie et moi je les ai vu un jour je les
ai vu un jour on était au restaurant
tous les deux il ya une fille qui passe
comme ça qui se lève
elle était sublime on la regarde comme
ça tous les deux tu vas sortir le temps
qu'elle sorte
il avait un bout de papier dans la main
et un crayon et moi j'ai pas vu faire
mais le temps que la fille sorte chez
pac en même temps l'ami pas trop
longtemps il a griffonné en la regardant
la fille sur le papier la fille qui est
en train de sortir et tout d'un coup je
baisse la tête je vois le papier j'avais
l'impression de voir une photo de la
fille c'est un génie ce n'est pas vrai
un génie un croit alors que l'excès
d'alcool et de tabac les ont provoqué
plusieurs soucis de santé en 89 on
l'hospitalise plusieurs fois et les
médecins lui disent qu'il est s'il
continue à voir il risque de perdre la
vue regardez son intervention côté de sa
marionnette des guignols le 10 mai 81 9
où il revient sur les rumeurs liées à
son opération la serge ça avec vous
viviez en marge mais aujourd'hui on peut
dire que vous êtes un authentique
desperados puisque depuis votre
opération
vous vivez sans foi ni loi non en fait
la vérité là voilà le premier qui me
tarde l'opération premier qui me parle
de cirrhose ou de cancer lui casse la
gueule parce que sireau ça se perd pas
on m'a trouvé une saloperie que j'ai
attrapé en afrique
voilà la fête bonjour les puits etc ont
crevé mais aussi du conte bailleul suivi
bois cet [ __ ] moi j'ai plus le droit
caceres simplement à cette époque très
très très peur ouais il a réussi à
arrêter l'alcool et le tabac un petit
peu un petit peu mieux que moi
complètement pris l'eau du cercueil quoi
il fumait autant ville et il d'abord il
a commencé très jeune c'était il allume
et toutes les cinq secondes toutes les
oueds tout le temps c'était une
gestuelle c'était un esthétisme ajouté
que les briques et qu'il fallait qu'il
arrête vous jean-jacques ou non mais
c'était une autre époque déjà on parlait
beaucoup moins d'aidés méfaits du tabac
à fumer partout dans les restaurants
dans l'est que dans les taxis ont pas se
rendre compte
et pourtant il le savait on le savait
quand même mais mais j'étais incapable
d'arrêter
il a surtout eu une enfance extrêmement
difficile il faut comme le rappeler
parce que comme il était sous le régime
de vichy à son voilà comme il était juif
il s'est caché dans une école dans le
centre de la france alors venu le
chercher et c'est ça a été terrible et
qu'il était né sous une bonne étoile
jaune à l'époque frénétique cabinet en
phase très difficile aussi folle et
alors le héros déchu de sa nationalité
française aussi à ce moment là le 2 mars
91 serge gainsbourg nous quitte et d'une
crise cardiaque à son domicile
on a souhaité revoir sa dernière
interview télé c'était le 14 novembre 90
sur canal+ serge raconte ce qu'il va
laisser derrière lui après sa mort
regardez c'est très touchant
si ce qui maintiendrait son exercice a
confirmé femmes on abuse and food
il faut surtout passer l'info alors vous
souvenez de l'annoncé de son décès ou
souvenir de ce jour là oui bien sûr
alors nous
enfin l'annoncé a été faite le dimanche
matin et met tout le monde sans appel
c'est ensemble à l'époque vous étiez
ben oui en plus et donc comment vous
l'avez appris c'est moi j'ai un ami qui
m'a téléphoné un dimanche matin à 10
heures ça a sonné sonné je me disais
qu'est ce que c'est que ce coup qui
m'appelle à 10 heures avait jugé pas
décrocher au bout de cinquante piges
asinien peut-être un problème on leur y
avait un trouble et vous avez fait quoi
tout de suite j'ai pleuré
bien sûr est rien qu'est ce que vous
voulez faire si vous avez essayé d'aller
tout de suite à son nom ne s'est pas du
tout non non j'ai tout de suite vu si
j'ai allumé la télé qui avait dès que
les flics bareille passagers - là la
foule s'était achevée non non mais oui
bernard il est parti donc on vous le
disiez 1 2 mars 1991
je voudrais qu'on voit la couverture si
on peut la pochette de l'album melody
nelson
alors regardez le doudou cas dans les
bras à jane birkin ce sont douze bébés
de d'enfants un gala toujours écrit par
la suite à l'écrit reliques s'appelait
monkey diaries et le jour de
l'enterrement de de serge gainsbourg
elle a mis son doudou dans le cercueil
de serge gainsbourg c'était très beau
qu'est ce qu'il aurait pensé de cette
époque vous pensez serge gainsbourg
aujourd'hui danse oui c'est toujours
adaptés ils avaient même de l'avant ce
donc
il sera adapté jean-jacques pour moi
c'était un être qui avait une
sensibilité à fleur de peau comme on dit
et c'est pour ça aussi que j'aimais
beaucoup le voir mais je voyais surtout
la nuit
très franchement et c'était ce
gainsbourg là que moi personnellement
j'aimais vraiment beaucoup
jean jacques debout merci d'avoir été
avec une chose dont l'agonie m'organiser
constante c'est là ils vont ce
compositeur dans la kozah dehors
l'exceptionnelle constance meyer merci
d'avoir été avec la jeune fille et
gainsbourg
il aura coûté très chaude